[Music]
you made it weird with pete holmes
what's happening weirdos welcome to our
third video podcast or our like 900th if
you're listening to this
old school which i hope you are i i i'll
always love my audio friends but hello
to our new video friends this is ben
stiller uh he's an actor
and a comedian and a director he also he
directed my favorite show of this past
year which was called severance
ever heard of it it's incredible it's on
apple tv i absolutely absolutely
recommend that you check that out and if
you're in a need for a laugh who
delivers better than ben stiller check
out anything why am i plugging ben
stiller
he'll be fine people are we're glad he's
he did us a favor so we're glad that ben
finally came in to sit down and chat uh
we really hope you love it check it out
why am i being so weird today
nothing to plug is what i'm saying
get into it
i was venting i watched uh press with
you if it's okay we're recording now if
that's all right it's i like that yes
it's it's not a trap i just don't like
wkbbl
sitting here with the man zoolander
himself it's it's not it's not that way
um and i should say up top i told you
you're fine people that it's not a
gotcha show you end up saying something
you don't want it and we take it out
this is something we we build together
thank you thank you and you're welcome
and and safe and you'll have you know a
good week uh to think about if you're
like me you'll wake up at 2 a.m and
replay moments oh god yes i just do that
in life anyway
i do too i do too
since i got i stopped going on
social
i don't go on social media i have the
account what's wrong with you
dude i mean
well i saw you found the artist for the
severance opening on instagram
which is
such good it's first of all the music is
incredible
and the opening i don't think i skipped
it once and is that a fine compliment to
that artist i mean like they
really nailed it yeah and that is true i
saw him on instagram but since then
i got off of instagram
okay that's the one social media that
i'm not on i'm i'm still on twitter but
i
the instagram i decided to quit but
before that i i just stumbled upon
extraweg
that's uh oliver lotta the artist that's
his name on instagram and i was just
blown away by his weird animations and
really cool stuff and and it just sort
of clicked like oh this would be cool
for the show
yeah well that's so when i got got off
you know we we post we post but i can't
go on
and then when i heard that you found
that guy on instagram i was like am i
being an idiot am i like locking myself
off from
how
art is consumed you know like am i sure
yeah am i making myself irrelevant in
some way i don't think i don't think you
are i honestly don't think you are
there's too many other pitfalls you know
that you get caught up in like for every
one extra leg there's like 40 or 50 you
know accounts that you shouldn't be
looking at that or start you thinking
about things like for me just like in my
life or i'm like wait a minute what's
that guy doing you don't need this i
should be doing that i got forwarded
something i'm doing a tv show right now
and and i love doing it and i got
forwarded an article that had nothing to
do with the tv show but so i read it it
pertained to something but not it
directly but then in the article it was
like uh the show which is on the bubble
for renewal and i was like on the bubble
like i like i don't i didn't need it i
didn't need it we're like
but it's really yeah you get bombarded
with just things that in pieces of news
and information and events that just can
totally spin your day into a whole
different direction for sure we talk
about this all the time we're so
susceptible to priming have you heard of
priming no what's that priming is
literally we're priming one another
right now if i say kindness if i say
patience if i say silliness which might
serve this podcast right um you're more
likely to be those this is why
advertising works and they're all these
great examples where they they test how
quickly someone walks through a hallway
after having heard the word rapid or
quick or swift or saw the preview for
sonic the hedgehog they walk faster
ben here's a better one i'm going to
make your day better because these
studies change my life you get on an
elevator you participate you better
participating in a study you get in an
elevator someone hands you a cup of
coffee because they have to tie their
shoe they go can you hold this you hold
it later after the study which has
nothing to do with anything it's a fake
study it's a ruse
they ask you
what describe the man who handed you the
coffee right
ben if the coffee was cold
people say he was cold if it was hot
people say the person was hot this is
the world we're living in so one
comment whoa whoa whoa wait a minute
wait a minute
whoa whoa whoa okay
somebody comes up to you or me and asks
if we want to be part of a study first
of all yeah yeah but it's a fake study
but it's actually a real study
all the studies are fake
all the good all the good ones the study
is [__] you get in there and they're
like which one's a circle and you think
you do great but it's a real study about
priming that's what it's called
priming so somebody's doing a study on
priming but they tell you they're doing
a fake study on something else which
seems ethically already it's like a
little bit weird to me all of science
ben all of science is like covert who's
running and suspicious yes because they
know because human like you know you
read those studies this actually kind of
ties into severance which by the way i
want to say it i think it's the best
show of the past 10 years i really mean
that
it's a masterpiece well i it's a i all
credit to dan erickson who's mine we'll
edit this out we're going to edit this
out okay
uh go go to living hell all credit to me
the clock is jumping time in the
background uh to me and stiller no no no
uh what was i saying oh [__]
are you talking about how this really
these studies related to severance
somehow a little bit uh it doesn't
matter but can i just ask you while
you're thinking about it yes like the
whole thing
okay but the whole thing to me with the
study about
first of all the hot and cold thing it's
like somebody's hot like you thought the
person was hot good looking or just hot
like warm
warm i said like a warm person like
their personality is warm
got it that's so weird i know you're
saying people in life are doing this now
like intentionally like in business
meetings people are doing are trying to
like manipulate like well if you're a
methodology that people have to try to
get people to do things
if you're smart you are i i would say
right
door-to-door salesman i remember reading
this somewhere when you opened the door
they would start nodding their head yes
and and that was a a micro prime it was
a way to prime
uh you know this podcast is a lot of
priming a lot of times all and it's not
by design it's just i noticed when i
would share my feelings the guests would
share their feelings and that's
intentional because you're you're kind
of interviewing too so you want to you
know you foster the conversation and
take it in a certain direction right i
mean i feel like people do that
sometimes consciously and also
subconsciously just in life for sure now
now i'm thinking about that in my own
life you know when i'm talking to
somebody when i wanna not like for some
sort of malevolent reason or you know to
have some sort of an agenda of any type
but just sort of like when you're trying
to connect with somebody right and
finding common ground who you don't know
maybe
i think that's huge and what we're doing
i feel like and i'd love to know what
you feel like so much of my life as a
sensitive person
is sending out a little sonar it's
almost like i'm blind and like a dolphin
or some animal like that i send out
sonar and if you ping it back
that's how i'm sensing who's safe who
not only who's safe but who might i
enjoy so you might set out something
self-deprecating and if somebody sends
it back your way or i i have to imagine
you you do that do you relate to that
idea of like looking for like i'm i mean
i'm
literally thinking like when i say hi to
somebody
yeah you know just when you say hi to
somebody you don't know you're like all
your sensors are out and you're just
like okay how's this person going to
relate to my high
are they going to be
nice are they going to be straight are
they going to be cold are they going to
be you know are they going to like i can
you can get us or maybe i'm assuming or
maybe assuming too much about a verse i
don't know but like from just the high
how they respond to that you get
immediately you you judge them on a
certain number of levels right
completely nice guy
strict guy serious guy
you know uh all that and malcolm
gladwell's book talking to strangers
malcolm did the pod not long ago and he
said the number one thing we should
remember from that book is we're almost
always wrong with our first impressions
i i found that to be life-changing yeah
yeah we think we're right yeah for sure
and i think that's something
hopefully you learn as you go along in
life that you definitely kind of put up
your defenses sometimes and will assume
the worst or assume something from a
sort of a
self-preservation standpoint and yeah
and definitely you're proven wrong a lot
uh i know there are so many people who
i've had that experience with um
i've also found for talking about that
that when i
allow myself to drop my defenses
preemptively if i remind myself hey you
know this person is having the same
reaction that i'm having to them when i
say hi
or when they say hi so
when i am aware of that and can go you
know what i'm gonna i'm gonna be more
open that makes a huge difference
i was just talking to val about that's
my wife about this which is like when
you're a kid you go on a date and you
think you're nervous when you're a
grown-up you go on a date and you
realize you're both
you're both nervous you know what i mean
like right what lunatic
nobody i would want to date would be
just like fine and comfortable on a
first date like you have to be a little
bit uncomfortable yeah that's awesome
and that's just in life just the just in
life and encountering new human beings
and you know when you live somewhere
like new york where people are just you
know have their defense shields up all
the time and there's just you never know
what's going to happen on the street you
know and like because it always could be
like oh that could just be a crazy
person you know or somebody's gonna
attack me or it's you know uh someone's
wrapped up in some life issue and i mean
i
it's just it happens all the time where
you just like you're there's it's almost
like sensory overload so you naturally
you know go to a place where you sort of
i mean it's also different when you're
recognizable in life too i think i think
we put up our
are sort of uh you know
some sort of a protective shield when
you're walking through life just to
because you just don't know how people
are going to react to you also you know
yeah well i have to think it's uh at
your level it must it must be
simultaneously sort of safer you know
what i mean like there's times when it
feels
kind of nice like i love david letterman
i've said this a million times but he
said he liked being famous because it
made the whole world like a small town i
have to imagine there's exceptions to
that
and then there's times when it makes it
less from going he was from a small town
wasn't he
yeah and i've had that i've i've had
that thing
you know we're not supposed to talk
about these things it's gauche or
whatever but like i've had situations
where i go to a party and i notice
like there's a there's a chance there
might be a couple comedy fans and
they'll want to talk to me and that
actually makes me feel
less anxious like out and it doesn't
happen like somebody comes up and wants
to talk about comedy i'm like okay i can
do this and then i've had the opposite
experience where you're going and you're
like this is the worst i hate this i i
that was actually i don't have a lot of
pre-planned questions for you but i i
was curious
how do you find
being a public person like do you enjoy
it letterman style that's a good
question i mean it is
no because the first thing i thought
when you said that about the party i was
i was going to say like i have the exact
opposite reaction which i just don't
i i i do like parties the idea of
parties and i like i'm i am a social
person but i also like
parties i like the idea of parties i do
of people getting and the idea of fun
and it's fun and people are letting
loose and having a good time and music
and um
you are can i just interrupt i'm sorry
we're so similar i have a bit i do on
stage where i go i went to my first
party after the quarantine and it sounds
so fun the word itself is fun party it's
a party and then you get there and you
realize you're just improvising
conversations just
yelling where are you from and
and one more i'm sorry i'm talking too
much but gary schandling said to
seinfeld he said when will i be
comfortable at a party and seinfeld said
gary when you're comfortable at a party
you'll you won't be funny anymore so i
just want you to feel in good company
you you were saying that's exactly what
a party is though it's like going up to
strangers and like having to start fresh
and yeah and
a lot of the time you know it is a lot
of time if you are a recognizable person
and you're going to a party in new york
or l.a you know the chances are people
know who i am
uh it's you know i don't know it's like
a little bit of luck of the draw i but i
do like it when it works out you know
what i mean yeah like well that's
somebody who i like and we get into a
conversation and it's fun but there's
that thing of like okay what you know
okay we're gonna here we go you know i
always feel that my wife would go into a
part like here we go let's you know
figure it out and i i was saying this to
elizabeth before you came on the call i
was like you see this is what draws me
to you actually not just as an actor but
as a person is you seem
sort of
you're not like a juiced up
hollywood you're not like surfing on the
wave of stiller-ness
like just like rocking it out and when i
watched you
look i'm not this is not shot fired but
when i watch you on howard stern i was
so i was like uncomfortable for you
because howard howard's a pro
provocateur you know he's like he's like
why why you do greenberg greenberg no
money what you do that for no money and
like you haven't even sat down yet but
you haven't sat down and he's like i
don't understand you do night at the
museum i understand that's a franchise
that's a franchise right but then you
you do a movie like green what's the
cash for that what's the cash and like
robin's also trying to ask you what the
cash is and i'm just like you
in a very human way i mean this is a
compliment
you're not slick you're not like wow
howard you know one one for me one for
them you know what i'm saying like you
seem like a regular guy i tried to be
that guy no no the one for me one for
them didn't work out for me i i've tried
no i like the idea that that's an old
but i feel like howard it's gotten much
better with howard he's he's a friend
that was an old interview yeah but he
like you know his thing is i mean i
literally heard him talk like his thing
is he'll talk about movies like i want
to see good looking people don't show me
ugly you know another word for a
character actor is ugly person you know
that's his thing he just likes to yeah
you know relate to people on that level
which is great it's but it's but i yes i
definitely had that feeling of like yeah
you know how am i going to explain my
you know my career or my life to anybody
and you know i don't feel comfortable
yeah i'm not like a guy who just sort of
like embraces the like this is my life
and let's live it to the fullest every
moment right right yet i do feel that
inside i feel that you know like an
appreciation
of my life and being alive and you know
all the things that i have in my life
and relationships and and uh being able
to live
in a way that's really comfortable like
so really i'm very you know aware of
that but i'm also not the guy who's like
hey you know let's make the most of this
moment right now what do you want to do
when i meet somebody
or that gets adrenalized and juiced up
at the mention of your career and just
like ah like just kind of jackson
pollock's all these bright colors you
you seem
you reminded me i admire people who do
that though i admire people who can just
live without any
sort of sense of like uh you know
self-criticism within what they are and
can be comfortable in their own skin
like that i actually yeah that's a great
thing
yeah well then here's this sounds like a
charlie rose but really
how do you think you'd be as good at
playing like greenberg's one of my
favorite movies uh i love greenberg and
brad status these are a lot like a lot
of
real people real human beings you know
what i mean that are uncomfortable
would you be as capable of getting on
their level if you didn't feel it so
much it seems like not that big of a
step you know
yeah i mean
i guess
both of those characters are i mean very
specific characters uh especially
with greenberg i think it was a specific
character that noah was writing and i
was finding my own
my parallels in my own life to it
which were there but you know
that's
i i feel like almost it becomes more
than like how what's how can i show this
as honestly as possible or try to do
that that's you know what i mean if it
is something that i can connect with and
uh try to
somehow
uh you know allow allow that to come out
which is sometimes you know a little bit
more uncomfortable if it is something
that's very close to you too you know
yeah this i i heard what you're saying
that yeah sound i heard my own yeah and
it sounded like i was like yeah i was
thinking about my next question i i
really did hear you
and as you were saying yeah i was like
yeah yeah but why did you do greenberg
for no money i don't understand
no money that's what you really want to
know
it is yeah i'm really jealous of the
freedom but that's just like you know
what like i did it because i i love
doing well oh no
i'm not asking i am not i love me and
ben stiller uh
there you go
you've done it you've done it
i i would love to see that's like
adaptation where charlie kaufman becomes
donald i think it's great his brother by
the end
big push push in the bush bush um
it's all like i i've interviewed some
poets on the show and and i always
remember that they talk about like
asking for another poem is almost asking
for another heartbreak it's like
so i'm wondering
another way to phrase what we're talking
about is are you almost grateful
as i am in a way
for your access to those feelings of
overwhelmed or or anxiety or sadness or
fear or whatever it might be because
when you
my brother's like i love my brother
we're we're both weird guys right and we
watch greenberg and we see some of
ourselves and that helps us that like
ministers to us right
so are you grateful for your access like
are you grateful for all of these weird
maybe even uncomfortable feelings
because they make you as a better
director better writer like what i'm
saying is you wouldn't trade it to be
like a
maybe like a
simpler but happier person would you
keep in this path
i'm assuming a lot with this question i
would
i think i think i might trade it to be
happier
i mean because i wouldn't know
what i was missing right i would i would
be happy
is funny
it's uh i mean you know look it's
it's who i am it's part of who i am i
think when you're
able to access uh elements of yourself
that are real hopefully when you're
acting then that's a good thing because
hopefully then it's going to somehow
connect and be you know
be
uh some relatable and yeah but
you know i don't always
rel it's not like every role that i
uh
get or think about it i want to be that
but yet because sometimes i feel like
then you can sort of like be dwelling in
the same stuff that you've done before
too so there are elements of that you
know maybe in a role but
uh it's not what i you know honestly i
haven't acted for a few years uh because
i've been trying to figure out what what
i want to
do as an actor what's you know and it
hasn't been
uh as also i've been directing more and
enjoying that but it's a good question
though you know because i think
the reason i did greenworks is i loved
noah bomback's writing and him as a
director and i was it was just you know
somebody i wanted to work with and same
thing with
mike you know on mike white and um so
that's that's you know and and they have
a clear sense of that character and they
see something that i can bring to it and
i can connect with it and then you know
that's that's the collaboration and so i
get i get something out of it but it's
not something that i'm i think if i was
happy and simple sure you know life
would be
less complicated well that is
but by the way i'm not complaining i'm
not complaining but life is like for all
of us is kind of crazy right
pardon the interruption weirdos this
episode is sponsored by our friends at
blue chew guys confidence can take you
far in life it can also help in the
boudoir that's bedroom especially when
it comes time to step up to the plate
and that's where blue chew comes in blue
chew is a unique online service that
delivers the same active ingredients as
viagra and cialis but in chewable
tablets and at a fraction of the cost
you can take them anytime day or night
so you can plan ahead or be ready
whenever the opportunity arises the
process is simple sign up at
bluechew.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days yeah
the best part it's all done online so no
visits to the doctor no awkward
conversations and no waiting in line at
the pharmacy blue cheese tablets are
made in the usa are prepared and shipped
direct to your door in a discreet
package with blue chew men everywhere
are excited to see the postman because
when your package has arrived your
package
has arrived deal with it deal with that
joke i love it so if you could benefit
from extra confidence when it's time to
perform blue chew can help and we've got
a special deal for weirdos try bluetooth
free when you use promo code weird at
checkout just pay five dollar shipping
that's bluechu.com promo code weird to
receive your first month free
free
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
safety and for information that is
important and we thank bluetooth for
sponsoring this podcast
boom
this episode is brought to us by our
friends at babel listen for most of us
learning a second language in high
school or college wasn't exactly a high
point in our academic careers i'm sorry
senora centers i'm sorry senora kominets
it wasn't very fun and it wasn't very
effective
now thanks to babel the language
learning app that sold more than 10
million subscriptions there's an
addictively fun and easy way to learn
language whether you'll be traveling
abroad connecting in a deeper way with
family or you just have some free time
and want to expand your mind babel
teaches bite-sized language lessons that
you'll actually use in the real world
babel's 15-minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a new language on
the go other language learning apps use
ai for the lesson plans but babel's
lessons were created by 100 human
language experts their teaching method
has been scientifically proven to be
effective with babel you can choose from
14 different languages including spanish
french italian and german plus babel's
speak
speech recognition technology helps you
to improve your pronunciation and your
accent there's so many ways to learn
with babble in addition to lessons you
can access podcasts games videos stories
and even live classes plus it comes with
a 20-day money-back guarantee so you got
nothing to lose get into it start your
new language learning journey today with
babel right now save up to 60 off your
subscription when you go to
babble.com
weirdo that's babble b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com
weirdo for up to 60 off your
subscription
babble
language for life
i don't know man i'm i'm of two minds
because one i would like to see
people suffering less but then i'm the
other part of my mind including you i
mean
having just like a more
i'm assuming you're like me having just
an easier access to just like a carefree
you know whistling in the meadow when
bird lands on you this sort of person
i am the guy that's going like i'm so
grateful that that ben is struggling
with the same with a lot of the same
issues that a lot of us are struggling
with because you make it into art that
and to bring it to severance i don't
just mean as an actor you can't direct
severance if you don't know what it
feels like to be isolated from yourself
you know like or or what it feels like
to
be lonely i mean that that whole show
felt like a
like a study in
like a weird everyone's telling me
everything's okay but nothing's okay
sort of
feeling and if you didn't know what that
felt like i don't think you could do it
i don't think you could bring those
performances out you certainly get that
look going so so i'm saying like thank
god isn't that the point of life we're
suffering and we turn it into something
good isn't that like one of the
beautiful things of life
yes i think that you know you have to
take your own experience and somehow
especially as a director figure out how
you connect if you're not writing the
material yourself figure out how you
connect with this material and how you
can
become part of it and
it's you know what you find in it that
connects with yourself and i've actually
worked on that honestly over the last
few years because i think as an actor
it's more obvious when you do it's like
okay i got to figure out how to play
this part as a director you have to
figure out how to connect with the
material and put as much of yourself
into it as possible
and
i think uh yeah that those but you know
a lot of that stuff also is just sort of
subconscious stuff that just exists
anyway and you just like relate to
a feeling or an image or
you know uh and you know just it's
simple sometimes it's just simple
sometimes you know like okay the scene
says you know he's sitting alone in his
apartment watching television
and you've just set up the camera for in
a you know way that sort of like feels
like okay this is what that feels like
and it and all of a sudden
you know like adam scott's sitting there
watching tv by himself and
that's just there you know he's there in
the moment it's just happening and i'm
like i'm feeling like okay this yeah i
know what this is and
this is what it is you know it's just
sort of like you know happening
get out of the okay so getting out of
the way a little bit yeah for sure not
like feeling like you have to make any
statement about it you know
i won't tell the story because i like
telling stories where i'm embarrassed
because they're funny but i won't tell
the full story but i was i met paul
thomas anderson at uh largo
and
i i'm obsessed with paul thomas anderson
he's my favorite director
and i uh we almost got in a debate i was
like how could that have been an
accident he was telling me something in
the movie was an accident was something
that they just got out of the way and
let happen and now reading more and more
about his films i'm like
so much of it almost like a dream
was about a feeling like like you're
saying like the perfect symmetry of the
lumen office right kind of craning up on
as adam's walking in the pilot
feels
it feels right you know what i mean but
like he probably didn't sit around going
like it feels right because it looks
like a skull and he's so small
and like the scale it's a predator angle
it's a predator angle so there's like a
hawk that makes you think that there's a
hawk coming to get him like you don't
know i mean
no i mean honestly i can tell you yeah
like how that came about i didn't think
of any of those things and i and i think
you're
um but i think you're right when you
know the thing that i love about paul
thomas anderson's movies is that they
don't
they they don't have a genre they you
know he refuses to work in a genre and
he it just it's just the story and and
it's the movie and it's
the feelings and the you know the images
and
it's just what it is you know like even
if he in his head maybe has a genre that
he's thinking of or he's influenced by
or whatever but
he's not worrying about that and to me
then when you do that then you don't
have to worry about
satisfying any
specific
need of the audience or you know like if
it's a comedy quote-unquote which i love
comedies and done a lot of comedies but
there's something really freeing about
working outside of the quote-unquote
comedy genre because then you can do a
lot of comedy if you want and it's all
bonus and people enjoy it but they're
not they're going where am i gonna laugh
again when am i gonna laugh again and i
think that sort of pervades the whole
sort of idea of the movies or television
shows that hopefully can just be their
own thing and you know i think that's
something that's great that's happening
lately uh it doesn't happen i think
there are a few filmmakers who are doing
it
like paul thomas anderson maybe noah too
or you know in movies where they just do
their thing and and it's and but but
movies right now are much more
genre-oriented but television i think is
like there's a lot of room to kind of
just
be your own thing yeah
and and i'm obsessed with that it's
funny when i got a chance to make a show
the first thing i did was was sort of
what you what you did i probably learned
it from guys like you guys like jim
carrey and i was like i would like even
though i hadn't been doing it for nearly
as long my first break i was like well
second break i was like i want to do
what they call a dramedy which really to
me is like
i don't i've heard you say that comedy
is so easily judged it's like i'm either
laughing or i'm not every 10 seconds but
like there's not a lot of
leeway or freedom or room to move in
that in that restraint
is that what we're saying or are we
agreeing yeah definitely and i think
it's more like even like an audience
expectation or the way a show is
as marketed you know just something as
simple as that it's like you know like
the new comedy you know or you know
people it's just people show up to a
movie
and you know they're told what it is by
the marketing and
uh they're primed they're prime they're
primed exactly
you're probably primed yeah one of my
favorite movie going experiences was
watching from dusk till dawn and i
didn't know anything about it so you
have you seen that movie like
yeah halfway in it turns into a vampire
movie and
i was like this is the best way to see
this movie like what a treat i think i
had the yeah go ahead no it's kind of
the best way to see any movie you know
yeah really i want i want to see
everything everywhere all at once or
whatever and i know nothing about it and
i was like great
that's that's the way to do it yeah i
felt that way about worst person in the
world too like that one that came out
and i didn't i just heard it was good
but i didn't know anything about it that
was good and
so so rare we kind of want to know if
we're wasting our time yeah did you see
that movie i thought that was really
good i haven't yet i i believe well it's
because we have a three-year-old we have
i have a three and a half-year-old
daughter so like movies are and then you
judge movies much harder i know you have
a daughter uh you have two kids right
yes and once you're technically kids but
my daughter's 20 and my son's gonna be
17.
oh well oh yeah they're still you're
still dead all right i guess i'm gonna
call it i'm gonna call it
your son just rides by on a segway
smoking a cigar oh i think ely actually
looks okay i don't think he needs you
anymore
when i was 17 not to put pressure on you
that's when i really started getting
interested in my father yeah you know
what i mean it's like mom mom
and then like right around
when you're i guess
yeah you know becoming a man you go like
oh maybe dad isn't just as joseph
campbell said the hairy helper maybe
he's i can learn it maybe i can make an
alliance with him that's that's right
around that age yeah
yeah i have a pretty good relationship
with my son
right now um and and my daughter too but
but you know it's uh
i don't know man i feel like the last
few years have been so weird they've
changed everything in terms like a lot
of positive things came out of it in our
family but just like being able to spend
time with my kids but yeah i don't know
i feel like telling my son my son most
of his high school career has been in
during the pandemic you know
that's that's that's rough so yeah like
there's very like i can't go like oh
when i was 16
you know i was doing this it doesn't
correlate at all to what his 16 year old
experience has been because it's
complete like i was you know literally i
was not living in a pandemic i was out
doing yeah yeah my friends my parents
were
leaving us alone out of town and you
know so
um
yeah which is good though too because i
think sort of like with kids you have to
i i don't know if you ever had had this
thought but like when you had kids you
had this image in your head of what you
thought it would be to be a parent and
what you like what you imagined your
kids would be like did you ever think
about that like
of course yeah yeah like this sort of
idea this is what my son will be like
and
um and he's not he's nothing like that
which is great he's just like he's so
his own person so it's it's sort of like
forced me to sort of abandon any ideas
of what i thought it would be to be a
dad or you know uh some fantasy idea of
what well they that's another
psychological study that i took a lot of
value out of which is like
i the number i think is in the 90s 90
meaning
it's so much of it is encoded in them in
their genes in their dna and we think
it's us somebody gave me the image of of
a gardener like maybe that's
a trope at this point i don't know but
like parents as gardener like you're
there to take weeds out when you can
you're there to give sunshine and water
and not not to force this in
one of the things i was just talking to
dimitri martin about this and i'd love
to hear you comment is he's like you
think you're just going to be assigned
some kid but like it's you like it's
another you in all these ways and in in
francis hall one of my favorite no
movies
i'd love to talk to him about it because
it seems like he set up a whole dinner
party for one three second shot
maybe they multi-purposed it they had to
have but it cuts to her at a dinner
dinner table and she's going people love
their baby but it's you that's you like
oh big deal you love your baby it's just
you and it cuts away but it shows like
she's having like a tone deaf moment
with a bunch of parents right right
yeah
what does that make you think go ahead
no it just makes me think any parent is
going to be not you know is not going to
sympathize with that because yes right
because you guys love your kids so much
but you know that i almost feel like
it's almost a secondary thought where
you do have to step back and go wait
this is
very much you know my genes and uh
i'm constantly trying to figure that out
with my kids and like i'm constantly
sort of like going oh yeah that's like
me that's not like me
because because i do feel like they're
both very very different from each other
too they're just like very different
people and they're things my daughter
that i connect with that i can see
myself
and uh with my son also but very
different too so yeah i don't know i
think that's evidence to the to the
theory right if
if it was you then they would be the
same right right but
then there's also my wife who like you
know they a lot so it's 50 50 right
right yes okay yeah
yeah i like to think i won out a little
bit
just i don't know i'm a competitive
person it's like 73 i'm just kidding
let me ask you this because i really am
curious uh my mom was like
this was ridiculous she was like put put
leela in front of the tv and put on your
show and i was like that means nothing
that means nothing to her
i'm curious at your age
you have a 17 year old kid that's prime
stiller this is this is come on babe i'm
not saying zoolander is not for all ages
but i mean zoolanders are great these
are great movies something i saw i saw
something about mary around that age
what what are their feelings that's a
personal question but i'd love to know
did they give a [__] are they like who
cares it's dad we're embarrassed
well it's definitely
i mean first and foremost i'm just dad
i'm their father you know but they
obviously know you know especially as
they've gotten older they know
who i am what i do and it affects their
lives because then you know all of it so
they're it's interesting um
i think they both have a pretty healthy
relationship with it where it kind of is
you know there are certain movies that
they've connected with they grew up with
the knights museum movies
you know because they were the prime
audience for that and the ages that they
were when we were making them so they
loved those movies because you know
because they were like
10 and
fine can i jump in and ask did they
think then maybe it was normal like oh
dad's in the movie like what movie is
your dad at like it seems like they
don't know that much about reality right
well that's why we moved to new york
because they might have an answer to
that yeah my father's in uh clever
exactly there's a little bit of a bubble
in in that world in l.a at least you
know i i thought okay i grew up in new
york i lived in like for 20 years i
thought okay let's move out of la so
that we you know aren't falling into
that world where it is sort of like you
know interacting with a lot of people
who are in that same world um
but uh
you know they yeah so so
my son recently discovered i'd say about
a year and a half ago two years ago just
discovered tropic thunder
and
to my delight he loves it
oh great it's like yeah and he he claims
to be one of his you know top favorite
movies and so that makes me happy
because my son my son likes
you know like it's sort of like
you know like i'm like that makes me
probably you know as happy as anything
so um that he connects with it um you
know but there are other movies that
they just haven't seen and they're not
like dying to go see right now and yeah
that's that's fine you know it's
interesting though as a person because
you you know you makes you look at your
own ego sometimes and go okay you know
gosh i wish they you know
really wish my daughter would want to
check out reality
you know bites like am i like i don't
want to be the guy who's like saying um
hey you know you're 20 and this movie
might really you know you might really
relate to this movie that i directed and
acted
i
this is vulnerable but i said to val
when she was pregnant i was like
what because that's when i she was
pregnant when we were doing uh crashing
the show i did on hbo and i was like
what are this is i'm almost regretting
saying this before i say it but i was
like what are the chances when leela is
16 that i'll be doing something cool
like i
i don't like that i'm saying this
but the reason i'm saying that
embarrassing thought was that val said
pete she's gonna be
she's you're her dad
like she's not gonna be like like i've
gotten so
so locked in that my value is something
that i create i create my value myself
and i create it out there
so i was like why would she like me if i
wasn't doing something hip tell tell me
what you think i totally identify with
that i totally i get it yeah i mean
you know i i yeah you want to be cool
for your kids and you know and if you've
done things that have been considered
cool
you know it's like hey you know i hosted
the vmas back in 1998.
and she's like what's a video exactly it
sort of has the opposite effect telling
her that
but
hey you know i've i've had it going on
you know and have you heard about that
yeah have you had that moment though
that like i i heard you kind of
demonstrated earlier which is what made
me think of it
you're you're their dad though you're
always going to be there i mean right
it's absurd my dad
when i was a kid was like a greek god
you know what i mean like made of marble
you know i'm not saying like i
worshipped his footsteps i'm just saying
he was a huge
right jungian archetypal what his words
mattered his actions mattered oh look
he'd give me matter and i have to assume
you had that for your dad so
they they have that for you too like it
doesn't matter right yeah i mean that's
just the parent-child relationship and
and and i think it's
important to be aware of that and to
remind yourself of that
because while our own egos want this
connection with our kids where it's like
they can see us as a cool person
ultimately you know what you're what
you're saying is that the base
relationship is you know being there for
them as a parent that's
beyond anything and so
um
i have appreciated that through trial
and error over the years
really with you know with both of them
in in seeing where it you know like
where we connect and also what's
important to them and at the end of the
day it's like
i really at this point especially as
they get older and they're almost on to
the next phase of life where they won't
be around the house
my daughter's moved out already but you
know she comes home uh every once in a
while but
it's that appreciation for just like
hanging out and being together and being
there for them on whatever level and it
really grows it's a great thing i mean
that's what you know and then you just
think like i think my feeling for my
parents now it's just sometimes you know
we can get in our own heads and not
think about that as much
but that's the ultimate relationship is
just you know being there for them
what's up weirdos this episode is
brought to us by our friends at magic
spoon i was just off mike telling katie
i absolutely love magic spoon so does
val and so does leela but as you know
i'm often trying to be healthier trying
to cut out carbs sugar and unhealthy
food in general but i realize i
basically wasn't eating anything
fun or good anymore well enter magic
spoon which tastes incredible and is
made in a much much much healthier way
certainly than those horrible for you
sugar cereals that we grew up in grew up
with but it tastes a lot like them
boom they got their variety pack which
is all four flavors uh cocoa fruity
frosted and peanut butter it has zero
grams of sugar in the pack 13 14 grams
of protein and only four net grams of
carbs and it's only 140 calories a
serving that means it's keto friendly
gluten free grain free soy free and low
carb it is healthy
yet super delicious it's incredible i
actually had it this morning with leela
i also often eat it at night when i'm
craving something unhealthy it's a
wonderful alternative that you don't
have to feel bad about go to magic
magicspoon.com
pete to grab a variety pack and try it
today and show your support of this
podcast and be sure to use our promo
code pete at checkout to save five
dollars off your order magic spoon so
confident in their product it's backed
with a hundred percent happiness
guarantee so if you don't like it for
any reason they'll refund your money no
questions asked but remember get your
next delicious bowl of guilt-free cereal
at magicspoon.com
pete and use the code pete to save five
dollars off and show your support of
this show thank you magic spoon for
sponsoring you made it weird
i i'm so happy to hear you say that i i
find
do you've been a parent so much longer
so i'm always
cautious of sounding like i figured
something out but i figured something
out
in every relationship and it's really
true with my daughter
and she's three but like she's there for
it is if you can be
with them
like i said when i said
well and i realized i i was kind of jay
lenoiting you i i say that because jay
leno would off would give get [__] for
not listening um
why am i taking shots at jay leno it's
been 30 years what i'm saying is
i feel that my daughter can tell if i'm
there with her or not and from what i
understand
feeling like your parents are locked
into you
even when it comes to something silly we
were singing a song in the car yesterday
oh mr grinch um
and i was you're a mean one mr grinch
and my daughter went no mr poop right
she's i mean it's a killer bit
and ben like this sounds stupid but i
could almost get emotional i i said oh
oh you're a mean one mr poop and and
redid it
and look i love my parents and and this
is not i love [__] on them too this
is not me [__] on them it's much
funnier when i [__] on them this is
sincere i just don't remember getting
the feeling that i could impact my
parents like in real time like change
them you know what i'm saying like i got
the sense that they were kind of
spinning their own plates if that makes
sense
and that's why i'm doing what i'm doing
um tell me do you get that feeling when
you have moments of presence with your
daughter like this is what it's about
that's what i heard like what you were
saying and and really this was the
number one question i wanted to ask you
and i love it because it's baked in
with some with some compliments i've
always been confused by you because
you're you're a handsome uh
good-looking i just do synonyms for
handsome and it gets uncomfortable i
meant to swap to another keep going your
hands
[Laughter]
handsome you're debonair uh you have a
certain
i don't know you're when i when i was
young and i watched ben stiller's show
as i did
um i think one time i met you at a party
and i told you how much running from
bears killed me the last of the mohicans
treadmill
uh running from bears is still hilarious
um
but i remember looking at you and i was
like look there's a lot of comedians i'm
one of them
we can be like i i get this i i get why
that guy
over developed
his sense of humor what i'm saying and i
don't mean to make you uncomfortable is
good looking fit there's not a lot of
fit uh comedians
and i'm like what happened
what
what happened
like
why
why did you because
for me and a lot of us it was like okay
i'm gonna protect myself what what were
you developing this sense of humor for
and i'd really love you to go as deep or
as weird as you want that's that's kind
of the flavor wow that's a good question
man i mean
i you know it's not something i've even
thought about
like where did it come from or the
desire for it um
i think it always came first of all i
just i can't you know i have to
acknowledge that i grew up in a family
of performers of you know my parents
were
yeah actors and comedians
and
you know working all the time and it was
just our whole life so i think that that
it came out of
trying to figure out
how to uh
find my self and like what i was gonna
do and i
i don't know man it was like it's
definitely been this sort of push pull
over the years
because i knew when i was you know eight
nine ten years old that i loved movies
and i wanted to be a director i loved
directing and i loved making movies and
then the comedy part of it sort of came
in
and and my parents just being
known and being
uh sort of uh
there were always of stuff going on
around our house you know there were
new year's eve parties and there were
you know like rodney dangerfield would
show up at our seder and you know like
crazy stuff where it was just like it
was exciting i just got passed over no
respect yeah
this horseradish is extra bitter for me
hey yeah
sorry i wanted to see how many passover
seder rodney jokes
but it was exciting and fun and i don't
know like it just was like maybe it was
like a thing like i gotta figure out how
to be a part of this or i have to you
know i wanted to be a part of it and we
were going up on stage at a young age
with my parents you know they would
bring us up on stage after they do a
show or something and like introduce us
in the audience or put us on the mike
douglas show
and you know like we were out there so i
think in my head i was like okay
okay this is it i'm gonna do this and
the humor part of it
i i mean
you know i found the people who i
thought were funny and i was like i want
to be like that i want to do that it
takes a little bit of a
i don't know like you have to have this
ambition or something or like sense of
yourself did you ever feel that like a
sense of yourself like i'm i can do this
i'm funny
yeah you you have to i think you have to
be sensitive and i also think you have
to be
uh
almost the opposite of that like believe
you have to believe that what you say
should be heard like that's like an it's
like imagine you're at a bar one of us
is going to get up and have a microphone
and talk to everybody like that isn't a
normal impulse like you're you're a
child and you're like you want to be a
director that's not just
you didn't want to be the
dp like that would have been cool you're
like i want to be the guy that everyone
has to check with me like well first at
first i wanted to be the dp because i
was interested in the technical then i
realized oh wait but the director is the
guy who makes all the decisions and
everybody has to listen to but you know
but i wasn't the guy who had the ego
where i could get up with a microphone
in a club and do it so it was sort of
like a push-pull where i was like okay i
can't do that but maybe i can do this
and this ambition and this idea of like
hey i can do this and when i that
definitely was there and i think it to a
point where i wasn't as self-aware when
i was younger you just i was just kind
of doing it you know i was doing it i
think okay i could do this do you think
it helped i'm assuming it did that your
parents you saw them both as normal
people and as comedians that went out
and killed and were you but you also saw
them making a sandwich and you saw them
brushing their teeth you know yeah but i
saw them as like it was always part of
like the the normal part of our lives or
their lives was
getting ready and doing the work and
figuring out how to get to the next you
know
place really you know so i was always
writing or my dad was always working and
he was always
you know kind of figuring out what
uh was funny and and whatever it was
just so that was it wasn't sort of like
hey home life where we turn it off it
was just sort of like this is just part
of our the fabric of our lives is always
preparing or going off and doing
something or going off to california for
two weeks to do a sitcom or a game show
and coming back and
yeah
so it did normalize it um
i i wonder
this is a leading question so but i feel
like you're doing
you're doing great and you're not gonna
say you're not gonna agree with me just
to be nice i watched the gilda radner
documentary and i was really haunted by
it because she really seemed to believe
um
the showbiz thing that like if the crowd
is laughing they love you and if they're
booing they hate you and and we all have
that but we all have to sort of get over
it here's the leading question
did you
feel like as a kid you watched your
parents
get that love out there and then maybe
learn
wait i can do that i can go i can go
bring home the spoils and i should
because
and again leading leading leading but
like
if your parents were like me they killed
they're happy there's everything's great
in the world when when you kill and
something plays it's like the best drug
in the world is is to connect and to
find that perfect audience and to have
the routine go perfectly or the film
air perfectly or whatever do you think
you kind of
that's when the chip got planted like
that made you like me like oh okay i'm
gonna go and prove my value and added to
that was there a lot of
love and attention to them and then that
made you kind of want to strive to get
your own that's the second part
yeah i think it was all interconnected
because it wasn't like there was a
moment or you know like hey they're
doing that i want to do that it just
felt like that was the natural
correlation or the natural sort of like
um trajectory
you know oh they do that and they get
you know and and people like that and
you know the on stage laugh thing was
something that i never really
i experienced it when i got my first job
in a play
uh when i was like i don't know 21 and
it was this play that was off broadway
at lincoln center and i did a monologue
at the beginning of the second act
and it got laughs you know and
that felt really good and it almost was
like doing a stand-up act every night in
the play because i could i would gauge
the audience and it would it felt like
that and it felt really it was exciting
when it went well
um but at the same time i was also
you know wanting to do all this other
stuff too that wasn't related to just
getting in front of an audience and
getting the laughs so
um
i don't know you know it's but in terms
of how it relates to my parents
i think my whole life i always was
trying to figure out how to get my
mother to like really
really you know
love what i was doing and she did
but like i was but she just was not the
type of person who you know she'd be
like you know i'm doing like a silly
comment she would be like you know do
more movies like greenberg
you know wow
yeah but she she
i think she knew that i was interested
in going in that direction and doing you
know
more complicated deeper stuff but it
wasn't it was it wasn't always easy you
know when you're doing these movies that
are big comedies and i always felt like
yeah i knew that she appreciated but i
think you know i always was it was a it
was a tough thing and i think
you know that was probably more in my
own head
than
relating to her necessarily because we
had a great relationship but that was
definitely something for me i hear you
though but you you know you're like me
and it's hard to sort of
you can't know another person's mind
that that's the wisdom i i i hear you
demonstrating there so you can't know
but you do know your experience but your
experience was also valid so i'm going
to say both if you felt like it was hard
i feel that way so i'm doing a multi-cam
right now and my mom
maybe it sounds like just from that one
quote you gave me your mom two more
movies like greenberg my mom said quote
finally something we can watch i mean
that's that's what she said that's what
she said so
and
there's this
cocktail
you know um
bono said it i think i'm maybe he's on
my mind because i watched your bono
the bar mitzvah bond mitzvah um where
where you know he said you want a
overloving mother that's taken from you
too soon and a withholding father that's
that's the recipe wow but it seems to me
withholding from anybody
is always gonna you want that for what
to be talented to be talented yeah
and he and the he says it as a joke he
goes i was lucky enough to have both
um
i
this is like we've done hundreds of
these
uh conversations
i've run into that a lot that there's
usually and they become a phantom
in your brain like phantom thread where
he still sees his mother in the bedroom
like he's still trying to please mother
and or you know psycho is another but
that's the other experience
but like i i i'm embarrassed how much it
matters to me um
what they think even though at the sa at
the other side of my mouth i'll be
saying like i'm not doing it for them
this isn't about them i'm a grown man
you know
yeah well you know
it first of all it's great that they're
there and they can still appreciate your
work because like you know now coming
from this experience and i'm happy to be
working on a documentary about my
parents
so it's been interesting to kind of
delve into
a lot of their
work relationship and and uh you know my
dad recorded a lot of uh audio of when
they were working and writing and
conversations and you know it's like it
was an interesting complicated
relationship they had that was rooted in
love and and but this real creative
connection
but you know just to have now that
they're not there
that's that's the interesting thing is
to see
or to feel how much i think about them
when i'm doing something and how think
about how they would react to it
and all of that i mean even
you know i even think just like in my
hair like where i let my hair go gray i
think about like my dad would be like
don't do that
you know like just gotta keep a little
keep a little dark in there just uh oh
my god you know that kind of you know
he's like sort of like the show business
thing you know yeah yeah you know run a
little shoe polish through there benny
like they they like how they remember
you you know
because he loved you know he mattered to
him you know his connection with the
audience it filled him with you know a
lot of joy because he grew up in a very
withholding uh family and you know
during the depression and so his
connection with making an audience laugh
when people come up to him on the street
really you know filled him up yeah
here's here's a there was another yeah
that sounded like i wasn't listening it
filled him up he had a connection i i
could repeat everything he said
i don't know why i'm planting in your
mind that i'm not listening you're not
thinking that but i keep making sure you
know i know why it's because i watched
that stern thing i was like he's not
even listening anyway um
a long time ago
i wonder
like
you said i heard you say somewhere that
your daughter is interested in acting
and and is your son possibly maybe two
he's pretty young he's pretty young but
my daughter is going to drama school so
she's serious about it yeah
well what i wonder if
when
let's say your daughter uh starts
getting big on something like tic toc or
something if if there might be like uh
you're like yeah but it's not a film you
know i'm not saying you would say that
in the same way you do the ben stiller
show which was sort of your your big
your first big break i wonder if they
were like yeah but it's not in front of
their live audience there's no razzle
dazzle you know like how are you gonna
know if it's working i wonder if it was
confusing to them that you're like no we
do these sketches it's on mtv
like do you remember their response to
to that yeah no they got that because
they were actually doing sketch comedy
too and i think they totally understood
what i was doing and they they were
actually a part of when i was starting
out i was making audition tapes for
saturday night live and i did like a
whole tape with a theme where i went to
my parents and i told them that i wanted
to be
uh on snl and i needed some material
from them and i did like i have i have
the the raw footage of this thing i did
with my parents where like i'm telling
my parents like give me some material
and then i went up and visited my dad
who was at the williamstown theater
festival we did a whole takeoff on death
of a salesman i mean like where i went
up to see him there and he he was like
having an affair with some actress and i
walked in on he was like this crazy
psycho
i mean it was and but they totally were
there for all of it like they just were
like i'm bored so they definitely got it
i think they probably looked at me like
okay ben's doing his thing and he really
you know he really is like he has an
idea of what he wants to do so like you
know
we support it but like go do your thing
but but but i don't i don't think they
ever didn't understand that was one of
the great things about growing up with
parents who were actors who i think they
got that you know yeah okay i'm glad i
asked i couldn't have been more wrong
though yeah yeah no no no no no no no
there was humiliation for me
no i'm getting it i think that that was
if anything it was
more my dad sort of and i you know i can
understand this as a parent like i could
feel my dad wanting it to go well for me
and that protective thing as a parent of
not wanting to
see me have to go through failure you
know which you can't protect your kids
from you just have to let them
do it but he would try to you know he
couldn't help himself from trying to
sort of protect me from that
that's interesting was was the ben
stiller show viewed as a as a failure
yes
that was a real question that was a real
question because it means
it wasn't viewed i don't think it was
viewed as anything i think it was just
sort of
it was sort of like it
happened um you're yes though i want
your yes to be my ringtone
with the exact pause
yes that was a loaded yes and i loved it
i know it was a very successful failure
because it like it gave me the next
opportunity i had two failures with the
ben stiller show it was the mtv ben
stiller show which was we showed videos
and did a version of the show and then
the fox one which we developed over a
couple of years that was after that and
that was you know got cancelled also but
then
led to other opportunities so yeah
well
i mean who cares i i also ha i had a
short i had the pete holm show
short-lived you've never even heard of
it those are the mugs back there and
i don't i i don't consider it a failure
even though my joke is i don't think tbs
even knows it aired like i'm pretty sure
they they're not aware of it
but like as a kid watching it it was
you know i'm sure you get this all the
time from comedians i was like that was
a thing that you saw and you were like
oh
there's other there's other people like
me you know what i mean that that yeah
that have the same sense of humor like
i mean now
just to be clear at the time i did i
wasn't feeling like oh this is a failure
at all yeah you know what i mean at the
time i was
like wow we just got to do that one on
mtv and now fox wants us to develop a
show and then two and a half years later
we got this pilot done and then they put
it on the air and we did it and it i
knew it wasn't getting picked up and it
was kind of a bummer but it was also
like oh my god we did that
you know and things were it felt like
things you know were happening and it
was like okay that that that got
cancelled but you know on to the next
thing and so yeah so and it was all fun
and it was all fun when we were doing it
for sure yeah yeah yeah
no i i i didn't think you thought it was
a failure but it was it was received as
a failure is so funny to me
it actually makes me
nostalgic for the time in my life not
that i'm so hollywood but like
i just thought it was good and it was on
tv
what a mitzvah you know what i mean i
was like this is incredible right but
that's that is honestly how i think we
all felt like i remember telling my dad
like hey they're gonna put this show on
the air and that was like really
exciting
and then it was on the air and we were
doing it and we were going to the
network you know the television critics
association thing and we were you know
like i remember like going to fox
parties and you know toby maguire was
there with his show great scott and like
you know
herman's head was having these other
sitcoms
because they had you know they had like
eight hours of programming a week at
that time
and it was just exciting because there's
nothing like those first jobs when you
know you're starting out it's just like
oh my god we're doing it
did you
i struggled a little bit
chris rock has a great line where he's
like when they take a comedian and give
him a show it's like taking a waiter and
giving him a restaurant
and i
i relate hard to that
when the when my show was done we did 80
episodes it was on every day though uh
so whoa there was a fly in here um there
are flies in here and ben i want you to
know i sl i killed one like obama
like i got him and uh five minutes later
he's up and about again he's he's he's
doing fine
um i have lazy survivor i haven't
deleted
my house yeah
i we had that at uh the bennigan's i
worked at and ladybugs as a pest uh the
cuteness factor is uh it's so cute no
it's not cute at all yeah you get them
on their back and those legs and the
wings come out they look like any other
insect
it's the polka dots and the reds the
polka dots yeah where it's like a
children's umbrella that that doesn't
work when they're on their back
then they just look like what they are
which is something from dune like coming
out of the sand to kill you it's an
unpleasant bug no you you're this is we
finally have our click bait ben stiller
shots fired on uh ladybugs
um what was i saying
do you remember about being um
having a uh oh yeah yeah you got a
restaurant you got a restaurant so
i'm only saying this um to see if you
can relate is is
when the show was done i had this like
postmortem with almost everybody on the
show and i didn't even know there were
problems like there but there were like
people were like oh there was this and
this and this and like there were times
that i
uh was feeling a lot of pressure and and
you know they they noticed that and felt
that and what i mean is i didn't have
any
office managing skill so i didn't know i
probably didn't know this on crashing
either to like check in and make sure
people are good and incentivize my
workers and all this stuff that why the
why would i know any of that
uh what does that bring to mind for you
with your first show and it's your name
i think there's something about that
you know the what it brings to mind for
me is just it took me a long time and
i'm saying like maybe like 25 or 30
years of doing it to realize
how important that is you know the
demeanor what you put out there if
you're heading something up you know and
i think as a director
that's what i finally started to
understand because i used to look at it
in a way that was much more sort of
um
maybe sometimes mercenary going in you
know like oh i'm going to protect the
actors in this scene
you know in my first movies and
not thinking about how to talk to the
crew and not you know not really
understanding that oh wait if i want to
get the best out of everybody
then everybody has to feel that they're
being related to on a on a really
human and open level and i didn't do
that as well and i you know and i so i i
feel like it's taken me time what you're
saying is very relevant when you walk in
a room just say hey because you're the
invol you're the boss you're in charge
everybody is kind of going off of your
energy
and um i was less self-aware for a long
time about that because i didn't think
like well what are they really they're
really going to care about how where i'm
coming from
right right so it actually was coming
from a humble place but well humble but
then sometimes also less self-aware and
then i i mean i'll say like i feel like
i could i could be arrogant sometimes
and think that same idea of like
thinking i knew what i was doing
when i really didn't know as much what i
was doing but sometimes that like
thinking you know what you're doing is
what gets gets you through to be able to
like actually go and make choices
i completely relate to what you're
saying so sometimes what's happening is
it's spilling over it's something you
need you need to be able to like hype
yourself up
and then it spills over a little bit in
a negative way yeah or in a not helpful
way right and that's just i think for me
it was like just my
youth and where i was at in my life and
just not knowing that you know and
sometimes it's all mixed in um so
um i think that's very valid and
you know i think uh you know let's let's
face it like when you're doing these
shows like you're doing a show and
you're starring in a show that's a lot
of pressure
on you mm-hmm right and you and then
like how do you kind of like let that be
fun be the fun sort of like i love doing
my show and
you know i love being peter
you know you know what the secret is
that i've learned from going from
crashing to the show i'm on is uh don't
be in every scene don't write every
episode you know what it was like right
that was like a one like i understand
i heard greta gerwig actually say that
directing was her favorite thing that
she's ever done we went and saw lady
bird and there was a q a afterwards and
i i was sort of surprised at that point
in my life that she said hearing someone
else say what i wrote while i watched
was way better than being in front of
the camera and now i'm slowly starting
to understand i don't know if that means
i'm getting it out of my system or what
how is that what it feels like to you is
there's like a
there's like a settling there's a
maturity i don't mean bad settling i
mean like the sediment has settled and
you're more clear for sure i mean even
just literally not acting and directing
you know the last few years and just
directing just doing one thing at a time
the first day of shooting on escape at
dannemora which is really the first
thing i directed since probably cable
guy that i wasn't really in
uh
it was so enjoyable the first day i
remember just having this feeling oh my
god this is gonna be great because i
love doing this i love directing and
yeah i love acting too and but directing
and acting would be
you know it's the thing where like it'd
be fun to set up the shot and figure out
what the scene was and then you have to
jump in front of the camera and you have
to do it you know and that part that
part then you have to go back and watch
yeah
if it's good enough or not and you know
all that
can't be good for acting that can't be
good i would never want to watch the
last take because
it's like i think of adam driver who
doesn't watch his movies and stuff i'm
like i get it you're trying to get out
of the way but you're directing your own
movie it sort of seems insane
imagine if you were that kind of actor
and and you directed your own movies
i don't watch my takes or the movie but
i will listen i'll listen to the cut
yeah listen to the god and give notes
that's the problem because i want to be
that kind of actor you know and uh yeah
and owen will like that too i don't
think he's like i think he told me the
other day like just the other day that
like somehow his son was watching
zoolander or something and saw scene and
like he was talking about some scene in
zoolander that he saw for the first time
like two weeks ago
wow
okay
something i i find that hilarious and i
love the restraint to not even try the
impression that was very fun
i had i hadn't even i hadn't even seen
it that's pretty good
it was zoolander i mean i know you're
good friends so
what was my character's name
you know
this is a safe space podcast we can try
any impression
um
here's a very
uh okay so the last thing i was doing i
noticed that i'm a comedian and when i'm
reading a script um i do think about
what my character is feeling but then
there's this crust to the pie that i
can't and don't want to shake which is
i'm thinking what is the funniest way to
say it i i maybe that's not the best way
to get at it but i happen to think it is
i go i know the writers laughed when
they wrote this in the room
and i know there's the perfect like
cracking is safe there's a way to say it
maybe it's like christopher walken maybe
it's like this maybe it's like you have
to find it and it's about timing and
sometimes it's about tripping up your
timing and then i've worked with other
uh people just recently that are like i
don't think about that at all all i
think about is what is my character
feeling and i i'd love to get your
answer and i'm going to load you with a
specific moment it's
it's something that val and i love so
much it's in starsky and hutch which i
think is a really
a perfect movie i think it's wonderful
and there's that moment where you'd go
do it
and when i first saw it
i just didn't know i don't want to make
you uncomfortable i just was like what
the [__] am i looking at i'm laughing at
a pause i'm like the line is do it do it
now i really want to know
were you or or you know if you were to
do that today are you thinking okay i'm
starsky i'm undercover i don't know how
to be a guy
or are you thinking what i would be
thinking which is this would be funny
i'm just thinking as pitoms this would
be funny if he has like a really
grotesque long pause in between it that
is so weird and that'll be funny like
can you can you help me into the process
a little bit um yeah i mean i can just
tell you that
it was a sketch that we it was a
character that we did in a sketch on the
ben stiller show with which was based on
sort of like this impression of like a
guy that i would you know
be a friend of mine uncle arnie's or
whatever so that's what it was it was
like and that was the sketch it was like
the do it do it you know
we play with that
um you know like uncomfortable thing of
like people coming up and asking for an
autograph or whatever and you know so so
that was very calculated yeah
so was it what yeah go ahead and work
out just we were trying to work a sketch
character into that movie in that but
but
if you are you know interested in terms
of just overall comedically you know i
think like in comedies you have a sense
of what's funny and you have a sense of
the tone of the movie
but it's i think it differs from scene
to scene where you're just in the moment
because you always want to be coming
from just the reality of the moment but
you know yeah it's impossible not to
know sometimes in your head okay this
might be funny i think that sometimes
can be the enemy of uh originality
though sometimes because
maybe if you've done it for a while like
you know we're to the point where you
know you do have rhythms that people
know
come naturally but then they become a
thing that you you know almost gets
written into something you're doing
right right right or you've written it
in or somebody's written it and you know
that's the situation so
but yet it still remains funny
yeah and that whatever that situation is
i mean and i love watching comedians or
comedic actors do stuff like that where
you know where that timing is just it
makes you laugh anyway but i think
you're always trying to figure out a way
to be
you know in the moment with it and then
and see where it goes and
uh but i don't i didn't like doing that
when it when it would be sort of like if
it's too calculated i feel like oh this
isn't i shouldn't do this because it's
too calculated
right you know what i mean yeah i i do
know what you mean i i think
i maybe i'm flattering myself and saying
we're similar what i do
and i can't help it it sounds like
you're the same i think i know there's
ways that i've done this in the past
i've done a joke like this you almost
like know this the shape of the joke the
sound and the color of the joke and
you're like i think it's this kind of
joke
but i'm so worried about like
not understanding so i really want to
know what the writer meant i want to
know like
and then maybe i'll forget it but i want
to know they mean it like this kind of
joke
and then when you
say action
or the director says action i do try to
throw it away but i always want it
seasoning
whatever natural moment but just because
i don't know maybe it's from being a
writer like i'm sure you've written
things where it's like
you just want to go in and be like
you can't i mean some actors let you
give them a read but i always appreciate
it but you want to be like maybe it's
more like
maybe
you know what i mean like like maybe try
one you're going maybe i really you know
when sometimes people go maybe
and that's just what i was picturing
like that is why i'd be a bad director
because that's all i'd want to do i'd
try and nudge them towards what i was
thinking no but that's totally
legitimate because sometimes something's
written that way and that's what's going
to be that that's why it was written
that way because it'd be funny to be
said like like when somebody's missing
that
yeah it's it's the
most frustrating thing i think as a
comedy director because you're like no
no that's not and
i the best actors that i know are always
open
to if you want to you know if you're
doing a scene where there's a comedy
moment and you say you know what i'm
they're open to a line and i tell you
what i'm thinking i when did it become
okay i'm glad you've you validated me i
don't know when it became a thing you do
voiceover especially in voiceover just
tell me like you've already seen the
animatic could you just tell me what it
is but like it became this
idea in hollywood don't give don't give
them a read don't give them a read
actors don't like reads it's like giving
me the answer and then i can play with
it but i'd like to know the answer right
right yeah i mean i think
my experience as a director is you know
if you don't give a line reading
and the actor is good you're going to
get a lot of interesting stuff that's
going to be organic and then it might be
end up being really good um but might be
better yeah it might be better but
if you have something in your head that
you want to hear then you know you just
before it's like you're never going to
do this
line again so like hey can we just do
one take where you try this you know
yeah yeah i love it yeah and a lot i
love it when actors also will come up to
me when i'm talking because sometimes i
do try to do that where i'm trying to
tell them an idea or something and
sometimes they'll say to me
just give me the line hey you wanna tell
me how to say it and sometimes that can
be great i've had it though sometimes
where i go you know what i don't there
is no actual way you know like there
isn't a way that i necessarily want to
just go do your thing but
you know it's uh it's always you know
it's it's a give and take i just like i
like when actors aren't that precious
where they're not worrying about like oh
i have to do this you know like they're
open to whatever like let's just you
know let's make it work well i think
about that i just watched uh black mass
the johnny depp movie and i'm watching
him and i'm like there's there's like
funny moments like he's telling his son
um you didn't get in trouble for hitting
a kid at school you got in trouble for
hitting and hitting a kid in school
where other people could see
and his uh son's mother goes you
shouldn't be telling him that and johnny
depp i think i can do it he goes no babe
that's exactly what i should be telling
him right now like he says it's sort of
like without moving see this i think
this is how we think it's like he didn't
move that made it funnier like he kind
of made this like earnest face like he
almost made an incredulous face like are
you kidding this is like gold i'm giving
parenting gold but i don't think johnny
depp was going like
here's how the comedy works i think he
was just going i'm whitey bulger i'm a
gangster like i think that's what he was
doing but i don't i don't think i'm him
that's that's what we've learned yeah i
don't know it's interesting yeah every
actor is different sometimes they have a
sense of that you know dramatic actors
have a sense of the comedy and sometimes
they have their own sense of what it is
but it still could be funny
yeah let's get weirder have you ever
seen a ghost
[Laughter]
oh man um
i believe in ghosts
okay here we go i've not seen one uh per
se but our family had a house in
nantucket massachusetts and there was
definitely you know weird things would
happen in this house
and
weird i yeah so uh
you know feelings in rooms there was a
baby who passed away in one of the rooms
in like the 1910s and classic i feel
like the ghost of that baby was in the
house and
things would happen um but never have i
seen an apparition really
have you ever
you there's really great ghost stories
on this podcast um
uh really
yeah i'm trying to think of
brett goldstein who's on ted lasso he's
great
he has an incredible ghost story and he
told it so casually with all the charm
of a brit and it was about like [__]
flying around the room and stuff like
weird weird weird stuff um
what about anything this is this is too
general of a question but like
can you tell me something
that you've seen that you just couldn't
explain maybe you saw a psychic
maybe it was a ufo
uh anything like that maybe uh i i hate
to be so grotesque and load you with
this but somebody passes and then they
come to you in a dream you know things
like that
oh my god um
oh god
i
no i mean it's pertaining to the the
house i slept one night in the attic of
that house
and
uh i
i i woke up like i was like i had one of
those like you know when like you're
making
crazy sounds like
that kind of thing
you were you were
yeah
i woke my wife up um
and i felt like
somehow like there was some
that something in that room was sort of
like taking like kind of trying to take
you yes puppeting me yeah in some way
and it definitely felt
it was definitely it felt very uh
unsettling um
ufos i've never seen i've never seen a
ufo um or in terms of unexplained things
uh no i mean nothing nothing heavy like
that no but i feel like the the most
supernatural thing is the experiences in
that house for me
were were it
okay
that uh
i mean that was a great that was a great
weird one yeah you just said you were
puppeted by a spirit
you were like yeah not really
that reminds me
reese darby did that he said that
happened to him on stage
it was in um edinburgh and they were
like it's one of the most haunted places
on earth where your show is and he was
on stage and he kind of got puppeted and
and the whole audience saw it yeah yeah
nobody likes this story i just did the
paramount theater in austin and i
googled it to see what it looked like
and the one the first photo that came up
was it was a ghost in the balcony and
though
i mentioned it up top but i was aware
that there was a ghost and when you
mention it to the staff
no they don't want to talk about it and
that never makes you feel good but i've
heard stories about theaters
my dad was doing a play
uh and they were rehearsing at the new
amsterdam theater on 42nd street on
broadway i don't know i don't think it's
there now it's been refurbished as one
of those like that's an eminem store
yeah exactly but apparently there was a
ghost in that theater that everybody
knew about too that was like i don't
care for it i don't i don't i don't i
don't like it how about this have you
ever almost died
like maybe when you were a kid got swept
away by a riptide
oh gosh gee
oh my god
i'm priming you i'm priming you for the
religious section we think about our own
deaths
no i mean the closest that i ever came i
think to
being afraid for my life like that was
one of scuba diving i started scuba
diving when i was about 14 or 15 in
nantucket also and i ran out of air
uh off of the like 50 feet down and the
instructor that i was with who ran the
dive shop i was actually an assistant
instructor his name is phil oesley he
still runs this uh store up in nantucket
the sunken ship is great guy he buddy
breathed with me and took me he i wanted
to go up to the surface
and he wouldn't let me go up to the
surface because he knew it was too rough
at the surface that i would have been
knocked into the rocks
so he forced me to buddy breathe with
him
and uh and swim around the uh the rock
jetty that we were diving around and so
there's no hand signal for that i i also
ran out of air uh scuba diving in the
red sea in off in egypt
i was diving in the red sea too by the
way really yeah when i was a teenager
yeah
why were you there
my dad took me on a trip to israel we
did a two-week birthday trip yeah and it
wasn't birthright it was just hanging
just hanging out and visiting went to
jerusalem went down to a lot
that's what i did yeah i was in
jerusalem and i went down to a lot
that's exactly what i did we probably
took the same bus which the tvs didn't
turn off it was the things i put up with
i feel like you're like me i like to
control my environment i always have my
headphones with me and stuff and when i
was uh in college i just took a bus with
blaring
like egyptian television
for six hours and i was like i'm gonna
see the pyramids like i just didn't care
as much i guess or
maybe
you know that just made me think of when
i was doing a movie in mexico in 1986
and the plane took off to go to mexico
it was like
i think it was a mexican airline and it
almost
i didn't almost crash but like basically
something happened and it lost power in
the engine and we had to go right back
and that was pretty scary too remember
oh my gosh yeah i just thought of that
when you said that you mean it just went
it was like
you took choosing air mexico
yeah exactly and then it's just like
okay we're going right back
and it was uh it was everybody panicked
was a little bit scary yeah of course
yeah
yeah no no i i was gonna say no me gusta
but that sounds like a spanish joke i
would have said that regardless
um
we always talk about this uh
it's one of the things i told
your lovely team
we like talking about spirituality
and without the burden of figuring it
out or or feeling like you're on the
record i'm just curious do you have any
i love this part of the interview we are
aware right now you know there's
consciousness exists like the feeling of
i am
emanates inside of you and inside of me
and that's a mystery that's a mystery we
all agree on that and i'm just wondering
what your framework is for that if you
were to engage with that mystery do you
have any religious leanings or spiritual
leanings um
[Music]
a good way in as often do you think
death is the end
do you think it's meaningless
go ahead
go ahead ben
do you think it's meeting that one
i'm also here it's it's not it's not a
monologue i'm here uh you know i hear
you yeah no i mean here i'll tell you uh
you know i don't have any
um organized religious
uh
practices i you know raised jewish my
mom was catholic uh converted to judaism
before i was born i was bar mitzvahed
and you know my dad went to synagogue
twice a year we used to go and then
but i never really you know was
religious um
my dad though was and he was well he but
he was very spiritual
and spiritual in his judaism i think his
practice of judaism my mom was much more
interested
in uh alternate realities and like when
i was a kid she was reading these seth
books you know seth speaks oh the seth
yeah and uh she's interested in quantum
physics and all these different areas of
you know
alternate realities and
uh
i have
always gravitated towards the idea that
there
is something there um and i don't
necessarily think that death is the end
and that's it and it's over because i
have trouble sort of reconciling with
well then what's the experience of it
being over in other words what's the
experience of not being
conscious well something would have to
be conscious to observe the lack of
consciousness exactly right um and
and i have to say you know
since both my parents have passed i feel
i feel a connection
with them and in a way that you i think
feel that people are close to you when
they're gone and friends of mine who
i've lost too that you know sometimes it
feels connected uh to something else
um and sometimes it feels less connected
i
i'm i'm curious i'm very curious about
that and and what else you know is out
there in terms of you know what happens
after we die
um
so you know my dad
i just felt my dad was like very
connected to that and like we took uh he
had like when we were kids we took est
and we took uh tm and did all these
different sort of
consciousness est was the earhard
seminars training uh it was
it was this very 70s uh sort of
self-actualization
course that then became something called
uh i think it was called
dianetics no it wasn't dynamic it was
although in this form it became
something called the forum oh there were
a lot of people in hollywood who were
into it but it was basically a training
where you'd go for two weekends as an
adult and they would and werner erhard
was the guy who ran like would basically
like break you down and and get you to
the meaning of what is it you have to
get it what is it they parodied in um
that movie uh semi-tough i think
um i've definitely seen it
i don't yeah it was a very it was a big
thing in the late 70s and then my dog my
my dog my sister and i went when we were
kids like we were teenagers and my
parents had us do the teenage version
and the kids version of it which was
pretty weird but um anyway what do you
mean
what do you mean how was it weird
because it was sort of this adult you
know self-actualization course but then
they had the kids do it so it's like
they're breaking down the kids over a
course of two two weekends where like
the kids to kind of get off of their
[__] in their act they call it your
act drop your act
yeah
and am i wrong i think actors liked it
because it helped you act like it helped
you realize you're you're always playing
a character so you can just play another
right yeah it was kind of a little bit
crazy you know i mean there were
definitely probably elements of it that
that made sense but anyway our family
was always always sort of exploring and
you know searching um even though there
were other things that we weren't
searching at all and like there was a
lot of dysfunction too but you know it
was all sort of the 70s there were so
many different things going on so anyway
for where i'm at now i feel
you know very much connected i think
just spiritually
with people in my life and
feeling that connection people who are
gone too and
i think there is something
out there and that we are part of
something uh that is not just the sort
of the consciousness that we have here
in life right now and these everyday
moments um
and uh i don't know but i don't have
bigger ideas about it um but i do think
when you
when you lose people who you love in
your life it kind of gets you in touch
with what that feeling is that
connection that soul connection that you
have with people who you love
hmm
yeah that's beautiful i love that i i
you've i've seen you take ayahuasca in
movies have you ever have you ever done
anything like that
yeah i've tried not ayahuasca i tried a
something
another natural thing like that once a
number of years ago
where it was in a yurt and
it was with a bunch of people and we
were all picturing a yurt anyway before
you said your uh
yeah it was the whole yurt experience
and uh it was some it was really you
know it was interesting um and you know
i think you know i'm not someone who's
you know
taking uh mushrooms and experimenting
every day but uh you know i think
there is something to those
mind-altering uh substances that you
know can can open you up in a way to
different
perspectives on
on our reality yeah we just do you know
well maybe you tell me like the est
thing
talk about dropping your act my
experience with psychedelics i i don't i
don't really do psychedelics anymore i'm
retired but like my experiences with
them were kind of what you're saying
it's like don't you see
you're
playing a part
you might be playing the part of sun or
right or brother or now now you shift
your energy shifts
i've always wondered this and you know
you're an actor
like you see
what what when i'm if i'm pretending to
feel this way i move this way like i
might walk this way this is how i sit in
a chair but that's what we're doing like
you go into a pitch i want to look
comfortable i might take up a little
more space or i might overcompensate and
look relaxed and when you take mushrooms
or or whatever you take
or through meditation
you strip away all of the stuff that i
would like to say it's non-essential
you know what i mean like all of these
experiences that you've had your life
they come and they go
but there's something that is essential
to you that does not change the the
thing that i love to give just as a gift
is like the the awareness like
it doesn't matter how old you are but
you're older than you were when you were
10. but the awareness
doesn't feel any older i'll say that for
me it's the same sort of
mirror or screen upon which everything
uh exists
and like
sounds sound farther or closer and
images seem closer or farther but really
they they're all put together on the
screen of your awareness which is
other traditions call it your soul or
whatever you might call it god it's it's
the knowing
in judaism the name of god is i am so
we're talking about em-ness and that
emphasis is you so i think all of those
are clues to your to your intuition that
there's more going on here than just
sandwiches and jobs and pooping and
sleeping
yeah though that is a big part of it
though
um
sandwiches are good i know i love that
quote i love that warren zevon quote
when he was uh you know he was sick and
he he knew he was going to pass away
that he said i enjoy
and eat more sandwiches
yeah but it's something like that yeah
because it was he was like saying enjoy
those you know things in life those
visceral things that we can enjoy in
life
well we're back to hanging out with our
kids if you eat a sandwich it's like a
japanese tea ceremony i don't know if
you've ever been
lucky enough to do anything consciously
if you wash your dishes consciously
if you talk to me right now we have an
opportunity to do it right now if you do
this
drop anchor into the moment
and realize that this is it this is
we can talk about our past this is it
then then i become
you're the university i'm the universe
you and and it imbues it with joy so of
course it could be it could be taking a
poop for real like if you do it
completely you see that the the totality
is in the the small yeah i and i think
that that the ability to be in the
moment and also then when you do that
you kind of realize that you can't as
you were just saying you can't be
anywhere else
and i sometimes find that interesting
when we're talking about stories and
telling stories
uh you're you can only be where you're
at in the moment in that story you know
that you're
that you're experiencing um and yes
right you can only be there in in that
very moment and
um i've sometimes found that helpful you
know with uh feelings and emotions or
you know not you know feeling sad or
depressed or
you know that understanding that
you know that's how where i'm at now i
had my friend stewart kornfeldt who
passed away who was my producing partner
for like 15 years he was
really into uh
different forms of uh
consciousness and reading about uh zen
buddhism and
um i don't know if he practiced but he
would talk about that that you know kind
of the idea of like not being your
feelings or not that your feelings are
sort of like passing through you or you
know and are well they change what they
change right
exactly and if you can sort of
somehow and that's what that thing about
the hallucinogen idea or you know
ayahuasca or whatever or like being able
to get this perspective and stepping
back and kind of seeing
your your being and your in your
existence outside of being inside of it
so you can almost like floating outside
of it then you it's much clearer it's
like oh that's just that
and that's what
movies do that too with characters you
know you know when you watch the
sopranos and you're like and tony's
always like i don't know why i'm so
stressed and you're at home going jackie
jr just got murdered and you saw him as
a son like it's so obvious right but
that's that's one of the things story
can help us with yeah
and i i would argue that watching a
movie
is sort of like being a soul
meaning you're a detached observer
meaning you're the unchanging witness
that can watch the drama and even at
parts you get pulled into it and you
forget yourself you're actually in the
movie like you are the movie and that's
like what we're doing with ourselves
there's a witness in us
but we often it gets obscured by
whatever the [__] it is we're worrying
about today like i i spent 20 minutes
worrying about somebody emailing me back
today
i won't even remember that tomorrow but
the awareness
is is constant and always the same right
yeah um
i also this doesn't really relate to
what you're just saying but like the
idea of watching movies i i always find
that interesting how you can watch a
movie and you sort of lose yourself
because you're
you know you're watching this this thing
that sort of takes that pulls you in and
your consciousness is directed on that
but then emotionally
it can connect with you in ways that
sometimes you
you don't you know in your life you
can't open up and that's the amazing
thing about
art that can sort of open you up in ways
and affect you in a not
intellectual way but in an emotional way
that you don't even necessarily
understand um okay
you stopped as if you're the host and
i'm the guest sorry i'm sorry
i just couldn't wait to compliment
severance
you know
i'm not gonna clear my throat and talk
about how this isn't a plug kind of show
we're just talking but for real
one of the great things about severance
was it filled a blank in a emotional
vocabulary
for a lot of people you're talking about
art can help us feel things and and uh
almost like exercise things that we
can't let go of otherwise until we see
them
in front of us as a story and i really
think severance goes even further
in giving language to what it feels like
to be detached from your true self from
your unconscious i've heard it 95 i've
heard 99 of our behavior is motivated
through unconscious things so literally
there is a severed part of us
in i'm pointing to my belly but like
somewhere in us
that's trying to get our attention
that's trying to get just like helly is
trying to send a note she's mad at her
other self but like
why do you do anything you have no idea
most of the time you don't even know
and before severands i didn't have an
image for that but now i have
more motivation to be quiet and listen
to myself and go like
is there anything you need to tell me
like let me drop
i'm the commander-in-chief
tell me is my job wrong you know what i
mean like
is this the wrong
i'm very happy in my job in my
relationship but those are good examples
and and that i just wanted to compliment
that yeah
as a metaphor for the unconscious yeah i
mean i think that's what dan you know
was tapping into when he wrote it but
just leave that out
that's what i came up with
um
no but the um
you know that that basic metaphor that i
i really related to was when you know i
saw that it was oh these people talking
like they're in the office or office
space and doing this like funny banter
this you know which is so familiar but
they have no idea who they are
what they're doing why they're there
right and that to me is like the
ultimate metaphor for life really it's
like that's what we're all doing here i
mean and you can explore it and get deep
within and try to connect but we don't
have any idea what any of this is about
and every once in a while you go in the
back and people with animal masks dance
while you eat waffles like that's real
like for you it was you got possessed in
an attic for me it's i had a weird dream
where i was traveling through time like
[__] is all that's why i like that
question what it's like we're in the
severance office and i go
what did you see at your waffle party
that's what that's that's how i'm
pinging other people
because the foregone conclusion that
we're just in an office
and we and we do good and they give us
finger traps that's how i feel when
people are kind of like
you know
like not asking any questions about
anything i can do that too i can do that
for sure and that that and and i do
i think about that a lot when i see
people
in life who are you know who i who maybe
it's going back to like the simple happy
person you know that we were talking
about like that idea like i do sort of
long for that but then i also wonder
like well is that person really simple
and happy or
is there ever that moment at night where
they're like thinking about like well
what is this all about you know i'll
tell you their any
is is probably not happy and peaceful
that that's that's it like i think we're
all coping
and some of us cope by being like i'm
just happy dan and you know like
whatever it might be
but
whether or not you're acknowledging it
doesn't mean it's not there that's
another thing that the show touches on i
also thought it was really
important
that
you saw drinking you saw
healthy examples painting you saw people
in all the ways that we're trying to
turn
ourselves off like grief like we just
don't want to deal with it we don't want
to feel child birth
right something we talk about on the
show all the time
and one of the things that i i think the
show's is kind of saying is like the
innie needs to meet the audi the the
light needs to meet the dark as soon as
there's manifestation there there is and
there is not right that means there's
here and not here that that means death
that means life and death birth and
death that means happy and sad but we
just want
to go around and and eat ice cream i i'm
i'm the same way i'm telling you and
then
let me load you with this and i'd love
to hear your thoughts on it so i did
that show in austin i was nervous about
it was a thousand people i was nervous
about it the day i booked it and then i
was nervous about it carrying it in my
stomach for three four weeks
until i did it and then after i did it i
was so happy
and i realized as i have i'm sure i've
called my wife a million times and told
her this epiphany i was like we think we
want to do nothing
we don't we actually want to do nothing
after we did something like we want to
we want to do something that scared us
and then have the day off afterwards but
then we're so simple we go let's just go
to hawaii for two weeks and then you go
to hawaii and you're anxious and you're
nervous and you're sad or whatever like
you brought you to hawaii it's bad
status it's the same thing like you
can't you can't get it so like to me
severance had a lot to do with like you
don't want to face stuff but all of life
all of the juice of life comes from
facing and incorporating
the darkness the the loss the shadow
the ugliness
like
i i i mean right yeah i think i mean i
never really analyzed it that uh
thoroughly but i think you're right i
mean that that the idea of face it's
truth too right just like acknowledging
the truth and i think with trauma that's
so much of what it is is just
acknowledging it and then you know and
acknowledging that we feel it in our
bodies and carry that stuff around and i
think that is a sort of one of the
things that's going on in the show that
i again like i never even thought about
that consciously but it's so rare and i
think you know the idea of the show also
is that you know with mark
he is it's always been sort of that idea
that you know there's his id and his
audi and i think the ultimate sort of
uh trajectory of the show over the
course of whatever the life of the show
is is those you know him coming in
coming together and becoming whole
yes and this is our simple guy fantasy
we're back to the beginning
is he just severed from his inning
right i'm saying
i think therapy and spirituality or
whatever your your
direction or your path to the truth is
that's why
you know
when i got i got divorced and i was
embarrassed and i was like i just won't
tell anybody about it and then all of
the good stuff came from this podcast
came from me starting to talk about it
it's hard to believe but in the early
episodes like i don't really want to
talk about it
because that's what i was taught that
was modeled to me like that's
embarrassing that's a failure
and to me
i mean
look to any major religion for symbols
of this it's like through the loss is
is the gain and i don't mean heaven i
don't mean don't worry you'll be number
one when you're with god i don't mean
that i mean it's through the humiliation
it's through the brokenness it's through
the you know blessed are the poor in
spirit like it's it's staring us in the
face and yet we go no
to really win you're donald trump you
have his hair you got the jet you got
your name on the building and you're
getting a [__] on the plane baby
that's not it that's not it
no and i think any um growth
comes from those
those
moments of
being of being in pain and being
vulnerable and because that's when
you're
most
open to really connecting with yourself
and you know and it's it's scary and
like connecting with that fear of
you know being all those having all
those feelings that we most of the time
don't deal with um yeah and when and
when when
failure or pain or you know uh a lot of
it also you know i i think for me i had
a lot of uh
uh separation anxiety because my parents
went away when i was kids i think when
we were kids and i really felt that you
know anxious attachment yeah yeah i
guess so yeah i mean just feeling uh
sort of like oh wait am i going to be
okay because you know i i
cause i
they would go away and then they would
come back it wasn't like they went away
for a long time but that feeling i think
was always oh wait what what what you
know am i am i gonna be able to survive
you know and then you see you can
survive
and and that just fills you with so much
you know uh it's just you get you grow
so much in those in those times of uh
those low times and those those scary
times
everybody that listens to when i'm
reading a book the poor listeners have
to hear me talk about that book because
i'm reading it and i'm reading iron john
it was uh robert bly wrote that book
about
it's called the book about men
and they these these
tribes had this understanding that it
was through things like fear and
survival and so they would manufacture
it it seems so
counter to our like male initiation
right it seems so backwards
but when you when i tell you that my
divorce was the first moment i was like
wait i can wash my wife didn't do the
dishes my ex-wife but like i can do the
dishes i can write the check i can do
like i can go out into manhattan and
hand out flyers and all this stuff like
it came from what i didn't want
and as a parent i'm you you mentioned it
with your parents i just want to protect
leela from all that and in my heart i
know
all of the good stuff comes from the
breakups and the and the losing the job
and the humiliations yeah from being
sort of like cast out of you know that
whatever that comfortable space is that
you create you know because that's not
where the growth is for sure
that's that's what richard rory says he
says it's such an such a strange place
uh mother teresa said it too god's
uh inconceivable hiding place and she
meant among the broke amongst the broken
and and the poor
you've given us so much time let me let
me make sure i didn't uh forget anything
almost poop your pants
we won't degrade you with that
wait you laughed
oh i did want to ask why you're off
coffee i'm also off coffee oh no i'm on
coffee you're on you're back on coffee i
am i was i might have been offered for a
while when i'm back home he's back on it
baby i i i had one the other day and my
my fists just closed and i get angry
i i i i really
i like coffee i don't know i haven't
examined my my real deep connection with
it but it's definitely like a morning
thing for me
i'm going to
i'm going to diagnose if you listen to
me with any authority let's never look
into it
let's just enjoy the sandwich like we're
talking about so many things that one
we're just going to enjoy the package
okay you have a doctor's order for that
from me um oh i did want to say
real quick we're almost done you must
get this every single day but when i was
handing out flyers in new york city
um for the club near the comedy cellar
you walked by me and you looked at me
and you nodded me nodded and smiled
and
i know this must be strange but like i
was like
that really meant a lot i mean this is
when i was starting not not doing the tv
show when i was really doing it i don't
know if we ran into each other during i
don't think we did but i mean i was just
a guy barking
and it really meant a lot to me and now
here i am saying thank you for that
because because you're you're out there
like it's the loneliest place in the
world and somebody you admire walks by
all you did was just like uh
the rest of the night i was like i i the
rest of the week i had to do it you know
did every day so thank you for that
that's so happy i didn't curse you out
or
well you did spit at me but it it felt
like a a friendly spit
um
and then the last
last question that we always ask because
we do get a little deep with that stuff
is um
can you tell me a time in your life
that you almost pooped your pants like
go back do it and go back
when's the last time you pooped your
pants that's not even it i i called an
audible i need it when did ben oh god
you don't want to know it wasn't when i
it's i mean
sometimes things happen right in life
that's all i'm gonna say
all right i'm trying to think of the
last time i did because i know
it was for no good reason
there's no like listen i had tried a new
restaurant it wasn't like that and i was
just like i can't believe this is my
life um we'll spare you that one here's
the real last question
can you think of a time in your life
maybe you're a kid um it doesn't matter
it doesn't have to be a good story
if you're laughing and tears are coming
down your face and you're and you think
you might die because you're laughing so
hard
when did that happen to you what comes
to mind just the time you laughed really
really hard in your life oh god um
[Music]
i mean
gilbert godfrey just passed away i
remember and i actually put out a tweet
about this i remember flying it was in
the mid 90s they had that mgm grand
airline do you remember that you're
hearing about that it's before your time
but they had there was literally this
airline that they had where it's like
first class but
it wasn't like supposed to be like a
private plane but it was like basically
like 30 people and it'd be like a weird
amalgam of celebrities and people who
were you know like
like i remember like flying once o.j
simpson was on the plane and there's a
bar or a piano bar it was like a weird
thing
and how did they make sure they were
they just had donnie they were trying
yeah it was basically like that but it
was sort of like the alternative like so
like if somebody was gonna fly to la
they put you on mgm grand they had their
own oh wow terminal um but it was like a
bad ex weird experiment and
i remember sitting across from gilbert
and
i honestly don't remember what he was
doing but he was the type of person who
would just do something and make you
laugh and then if you if it made you
laugh
he would just keep on doing the same
thing over and over again until you stop
laughing
so i don't even remember what it was but
i just remember laughing so hard
and
i mean it's the best feeling in the
world when some when when you're
laughing that hard where you can't stop
and what's the second time in this
podcast you were puppeted like that's
the feeling
somebody's got the strings on you
and it's like an act of grace that they
keep doing it
please don't stop please don't stop
it's so cathartic oh my god yeah but i
remember just feeling like that whole
that whole like whatever it was five
hours like being so
happy and just you know and you know
like exhausted exhausted flat thanks so
much yeah
well i i i don't i don't know why i'm
moved maybe it's because i love what you
do and i want you to keep doing it on
every front but it's so strange how
these things silly things gilbert just
saying something over and over making
you laugh
like that stuff heals our our innies you
know what i mean like something
it's going deeper than we can go you and
i can be like well my mom was sort of
gruff or whatever it might be
like but the comedy and the art
as a director maybe you'll enjoy this
and then we're gonna get out of here but
when you go to a movie if you've done a
powerful psychedelic there really is
something about the light and the
focusing your attention and there's
something about the aperture of a camera
lens you know how a camera will take in
all the information you and i are
panning and scanning you're okay i'm
looking at your eyes right now but i'm
blur like if you saw a movie that was
shot the way we
filter out reality it would be horrible
it would be like this sort of fish dome
everything's blurry on the outside but
when you look at a movie
it flattens it out and the lens is open
like a dilated pupil it's completely
open and lets in all this light and if
it moves slowly we have this opportunity
to get more reality than we do when
we're just when we're the camera
and then when you bring laughter into it
and emotion into it i told you that i
believe i told you that the meyerwicz
report
i don't know if noah had a similar
family to me but like
your character in that movie helped me
understand myself
when you when you go i beat you i beat
you i was like oh my god i'm trying to
beat my father like you know what i mean
me too i mean i honestly right i was
like i yes yes for sure i was that part
just tapping into very primal stuff
there for sure
and then when you fight with your
brother i have a very interesting uh i i
love my brother to death and what that
scene with you and sandler i related to
that we've never tumbled but i was like
all i'm trying to say is i'm trying to
put some some fluff in your in in your
fluffernutter
is that like i think it all matters i
don't just think show business matters
but i think everything matters and i
want to i want to encourage you for some
reason that you're doing beautiful work
please keep doing it and thank you for
doing this podcast wow thanks pete i
really really enjoyed talking to you you
have really
have really interesting ideas that
you're thinking about and the way you
talk about them is really fascinating
and i love how
interested you are in all these
different aspects of being a person
well thanks man yeah um honestly it's
great to talk to you so and you're
really funny too and
um thanks man
this is
unexpected
i just love it and i'm embarrassed that
i love that's so nice we should be kind
be kind yes no but that's what you
because you are you are kind and you're
but you're open you're so open to life
experience and i really yeah i just i
find uh
it's great to to kind of get outside of
the box a little bit in talking to
somebody about all these different
things you know because it is everything
is kind of interconnected and yeah
that's refreshing
i completely agree and and people are
going to love this so it's happening
right now you're making something right
now that people will love this is silly
we have the guests say the catchphrase
just to involve you the catchphrase is
keep it crispy it's just to give the
sense of closure okay it doesn't really
mean anything
um should i just say it or do i just say
like this is ben stiller saying keep it
crispy crispy
i [__] it up no i said keep it crispy
i want to get this
this is the best one can i give you a
line yeah please uh no no no no no no no
there's no right way to say hate when a
director gives me a line no uh it all
comes back oh here here's a weird one um
you can no that's i was going to say do
it as greenberg writing a letter to
american airlines and
but that was really just that was
selfish to demonstrate how much i love
greenberg um yeah uh how about uh
keep it crispy
[Music]
oh yeah